thanks to best buy for sponsoring a part
of this video you can get all your
gaming tech at best buy
hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are doing
another gaming q a if you want personal
q a's i'll leave a link in the
description they're not that personal i
just talk about stuff other than video
games on a separate channel today we are
talking all about gaming and got some
very interesting questions this time
around so let's uh jump right into it
paul jimothy said hey alana just
wondering how you feel about the last of
us part one being remastered again does
this really seem necessary
um remake not remaster worth noting
obviously
goes without saying
that sony um pays my bills
that's information that you need to know
this is still my genuine opinion and if
i had a different opinion i would just
not answer this question like if my
opinion was negative i would just not
answer the question rather than be
dishonest and also they have never told
me to say anything like this frankly i
think that sony would prefer it if i
said nothing rather than say something
positive from my perspective but i do
want to answer this question just want
to give that disclaimer first so the
last of us part one uh was answering
summer game first or leaked just a bit
before that and from what i'm aware of
from everyone that i've ever spoken to
at naughty dog about it um even people
tend tangentially tangentially a lot of
work has gone into making the last of us
part one it seems like it's been you
know
very meticulous um very intricate a lot
of detail a lot of attention to detail a
lot of love and care i don't know how it
even got the perception that it's just a
remaster it is a remake uh to basically
from my perspective understanding
catch the last of us one up to the
quality of the last of us part two and
this makes perfect sense to me in a way
that i feel like sometimes the gaming
audience can just miss
the last of his part one
again in my opinion is being made for
new fans um especially people who
see the last of us show on hbo and want
to try the game for the first time
who've maybe not even heard of it you
have to remember
video games are way
smaller really
than you think they are when you're in
the gaming bubble if you're watching
this youtube video then you know the
last of us you know naughty dog you know
who joel miller is you know who troy
baker is probably majority of gamers
have no idea even gamers who played the
last of us when it first came out don't
know who naughty dog is the millions of
people who game
are
not as invested as the majority of us
and when you consume this content and
you're on twitter and you're on reddit
and you're just talking to people all
the time you have the same level of
investment as you it's very easy to
forget that i think there are loads of
people out there who have only played
fortnite
we've never heard of the last of us that
would be curious to try the game for the
first time as a result of this show
dropping on hbo and from everything i've
heard it sounds like the show is going
to be very good and it'll generate a
bunch of hype and the last of us will be
back in everyone's brains again so again
this is just my perspective i could be
completely wrong and i hope that they do
like a state of play or something i know
they said they would be doing something
else before the game comes out in a few
months i expect they will address this
in some way and i could be completely
wrong but to me it seems like it's being
made for people who've never played the
last of us so if you're looking at it
and you're like it was just remade a few
years ago i i played that there was
nothing wrong with it the gameplay held
up fine even that perspective still
comes from nostalgia like if you played
it the first time or at least if you
played it before last of his part two
came out you're not gonna be as arced by
outdated gameplay and i do think it has
outdated gameplay because you're unable
to separate the period of time in which
you originally played it from the game
if you play the last of us part two and
then you play the last of us one even
the
remaster i think you would have a very
tough time with the gameplay if you'd
never played it before so again in my
head this seems like it's being made for
people who've never played it before for
any gamer who has played it before
i don't think it's for you the need to
uh remake it not only sounds like a huge
positive for naughty dog where they were
able to um
promote some people give people uh
higher positions within the company
specifically to focus on this project
because it's like a slightly less risky
project
i guess um for people to be able to give
and be given some seniority on which is
awesome yeah it's also just that if
people are going to be drawn to play the
last of us for the first time you would
want them to play a version that doesn't
feel super out of date with modern
controls especially if these are like
younger people who've only played more
recent games gonna remember philosophers
came out a long time ago at this point
in the grand scheme of game design it's
ancient not a lot of stuff holds up like
doom or tetris ladies and gentlemen and
so to modernize it for those people so
that they don't very quickly stop
playing because it feels outdated it
just makes perfect sense to me um and i
think yeah if um if you don't see the
need for the remake i don't even think
they're really trying to sell it to that
audience necessarily the price is a
different point and you did not ask
about the price so i'm not going to
address it because that's like also just
so subjective but it being 70 is
obviously a different point in a
different discussion but talking about
like why it needed to be remade it makes
perfect sense to me and i feel like if
it doesn't make sense to you then you're
probably not the people they're making
it for again this is all just my opinion
naughty dog could very well say
something completely different and i
could be completely wrong i've not
spoken to anyone about this the only
conversations i've had with people at
naughty dog have all pertained to
them saying that it um has been a real
labor of of love and and something of
like extremely high quality nothing that
sounds cash grabby to me at all it is
time to hear from our sponsors best buy
today i'm going to be showing you the
absolutely beautiful asus rg zephyrus
14-inch gaming laptop powered by amd
game like an absolute pro with the asus
gaming laptop powered by amd with a
ryzen 9 6900 hs processor to handle the
latest aaa games and a radeon rx 6700s
graphics card for an ultra fast boost to
fuel your gameplay
seriously not only is this thing sleek
and stunning on the outside but it makes
your games look 10 out of 10 gorgeous
too let me show you for fast paced fps's
and really any competitive game i like
to use the built-in mux switch to switch
to direct gpu mode to reduce latency and
boost performance by an average of 9
plus especially for a bright and
colorful game like this one the rog
nebula display is awesome it guarantees
minimum brightness color representation
refresh rates response times and more
the zephyrus also has massive amounts of
storage and advanced communication power
intelligent and dynamic cooling modes
and great low light settings and
remember this is a laptop so you can
just pick it up and take it with you
anywhere as well
best buy has everything you need to help
your game your way and lots of options
to get you everything you need fast now
back to the rest of the video booze and
bullet said hey alana what game was you
most looking forward to for the second
half of 2022
well definitely god of war ragnarok i
will be playing as dusk falls very soon
i'll be playing escape academy this week
i'll have videos of both of those up on
the channel as soon as i can very
excited about escape academy and you
should be too one that you may not have
heard of that everyone who got to play
at summer game fest was just like
unanimously like raving about it i
highly recommend you check it out i was
really excited about madison but
unfortunately encountered some annoying
bugs that have made me not want to play
i'll probably pick it up again in a few
months which is unfortunate i'm very
curious about the lord of the rings
gollum game i feel like we haven't seen
an update in that for a while or maybe
i've just missed it but
yeah i was interested in that and then
thought it looked kind of bad so that's
definitely one that's like on my list of
like things i want to investigate
further massively looking forward to
playing the full release of metal hell
singer i did an interview with david
goldfarb who's the creative director of
the studio there at the outsiders that
is up on the channel already as well as
my gameplay i loved it i wouldn't be
surprised if that ends up being my game
of the year obviously removing ragnarok
because that it's very biased i loved it
i am very excited for it to come out i
can't wait to play it yeah i really
wouldn't be surprised if it takes the
cake for me um i guess it depends on the
level design i think is probably the big
thing that like how the level design
turns out is going to be a huge factor
for me i think if it ends up being a
little bit too similar to doom 2016
where it's like walk down a corridor
large room corridor a large room
that if that's too long or the game does
that for too long i think that could end
up getting a cumbersome kind of how it
did in doom 2016
that said it's not like i liked the
platforming and doom eternal all that
much as a break but they definitely
expanded on the level design i'm very
excited about plaguetail requiem coming
out in october i believe um i played the
first playtale because of austin wintery
and really enjoyed it and yeah
definitely looking forward to the second
one i'm
very curiously excited about scorn
um i've been interested in that game for
such a long time like that weird looking
it's it's such a specific style and it's
so gross
um it's a horror game coming to xbox i
imagine game pass that's also coming out
i think around halloween and it just
looks so gross and so weird i don't even
really know what the gameplay is but um
i feel like i've yeah i've just
been so curious to explore whatever the
hell that world is for a really long
time definitely interested to play
gotham knights though i wouldn't say
it's like super high up on my list of
things i'm excited for i'm just i'm not
sure about it yet i love court of owls
so that's very appealing to me in terms
of storytelling um not sold on the
gameplay completely so definitely
something that i will play that i am
anticipating but um not as excited as i
am
versus metal hellsinger probably number
one again i know i said mental health
singer might not be my gaming year but
my most anticipated game for the rest of
2020 is callisto protocol um i've
already been in touch with the pr team
so we'll 100 have as much content about
that as i can i'll do like a
early gameplay if i can do that do
interviews and all that stuff i will
cover that game as extensively as i
possibly can because i'm just so excited
about a new very dead space looking game
from the team who made dead space or at
least some of them
it looked awesome
and so
gory and gritty and i love horror games
i'm so down that is
top of the list coming out in december
really hope it doesn't get delayed i
guess there are technically also some
other games that i'm sort of expecting
this year that
like i don't know if we're getting
dragon age four it's supposed to be
sometime this year also very excited
about that potentially it has been a
minute since i really loved a bioware
game but
hopefully they learned from anthem i am
also looking forward to the prince of
persia sands of time remake
i'm sure i've forgotten something but uh
i have a list that i i keep of game
release dates and those are all the ones
that i had noted keep all the stuff that
i'm really super hyped for so hopefully
i haven't missed anything i might have i
don't know there's so many games coming
out this year it like actually is way
more than i feel like i initially
expected at the start of the year and
that could be because more and more game
studios seem to be leaning into this
approach of
announce things closer to release dates
um which i feel is better for the
community
it's unfortunate that there's backlash
that people have to wait for too long
but
i don't know like xbox doing that
conference 12 months for the next 12
months of games
obviously santa monica studio slash sony
making the choice to uh hold off on
giving too much information about god of
war ragnarok
until closer to release date i feel like
it's a positive as long as you're not
yelling at game developers uh about
wanting more information which is
definitely a negative for the studios
because you're just harassing people who
are working very hard
i feel like the outcome is very good i
think it helps keep things more
realistic and if marketing cycles are
more contained
then you avoid uh other promises because
you'll more accurately know what the
game actually is going to ship with
rather than announcing things that are
subject to change like a no man's sky
situation cootie machado said hey alana
i know you worked at ign i was just
wondering how you justify the amount of
10 out of 10 game scores they've given
lately it's almost like every single
game is a 10 out of 10 that's why i
stopped consuming that content
i'd be very surprised if that was true
every game has been getting a 10 out of
10 from ign
i for some reason
sometimes people just make this up like
and i i don't think they're making it up
it's like they believe it they're
inventing it
without the dishonesty that making it up
would imply they've just convinced
themselves of something that's not true
like i've seen people say before but ign
gives cod every caller 10 out of 10. i
don't know if ign's ever given a call of
duty game a 10 out of 10. i don't even
know where that comes from high scores
are not inherently tense um every ign 10
out of 10. the only game they gave a 10
to this year
from what i can tell
is elden ring
uh which a lot of people gave a 10 out
of 10 too that doesn't seem to be
exclusive to ign
i would not have given that game a 10
out of 10 just based on technical issues
and there are a lot of things i think we
could from suffolk pass for however
it is [ __ ] incredible and i would not
fault ign for giving it a 10 out of 10.
it's very easy to justify that score
before that was forza horizon 5
before that was death loop which is
probably a controversial one i actually
expected press to review deathly very
highly i really love deathly but it
almost seemed like players maybe didn't
love it as much user scores didn't love
it as much um and that can come down to
like how much you appreciate level
design or how much you appreciate the
intricacy of that game or not i really
feel like developers love death loop
people in the industry love death loop
um and maybe consumers didn't quite as
much but i also don't know if that's
because definitely got dragged into the
console wars in such a weird way
it's a playstation exclusive game but
it's made by an xbox owned studio so it
feels like the console wall fanboys were
screaming at each other about death loop
and both sides wanted to hate it
so it didn't have any loud champions
from that audience who can often create
a big huff
a big very ridiculous huff
but it's like honestly like watching
console fanboys implode because
playstation had an exclusive from an
xbox game studio so death i think a lot
of people would argue but nah i get that
one disco elysium before that
a 10 that game is a [ __ ] 10. you
can't argue that one spelunky two
we're going back to 2020 now crusader
kings 3 i don't even know what that is
microsoft flight simulator 2020
i don't know i mean it's great i don't
know well enough to say
last of us part two everyone gave that a
ten of the last two years that's only
four tenths so
there's a lot of [ __ ] video games
that come out like thousands at this
point um that doesn't seem that
excessive to me matter keeps that i
don't remember you ever mentioning this
on your channel what'd you think of halo
infinite i would be so surprised if
there aren't multiple videos where i
talk about halo infinite there are
definitely videos where i play it
um
i found the multiplayer to be extremely
fun
but i put it down at the same time as i
guess everybody else did i don't really
know why
too many games coming out it's very hard
for me to stick with any multiplayer
game to be honest um unless i do it for
the social aspect i continue to be a
much more single player gamer much more
interested in playing single-player
games so i'm always going to put down a
multiplayer game and just occasionally
pick them up
peer pressure generally if all my
friends are and i'm asked to i will um
but i had so much fun with halo infinite
multiplayer i really really enjoyed it
felt so authentic
um to the halo that i fell in love with
all those years ago i'm not a huge fan
of halo 4 and 5. i have not played the
campaign though i played the first hour
uh put that up on youtube i believe um
but i said even before it came out and i
held to it that i wouldn't finish it
until co-op came out because that's my
preferred way to play halo so i'm still
waiting on that i will not finish the
halo infinite campaign until it gets
co-op
hopefully that's also this year that
could blow my mind this year too but uh
until then yeah i just opted not to play
it
such a bummer that it launched without
co-op it's such like a pivotal part of
halo for so many people it's it's a
shame and i think i will leave it there
if you have any questions for wow this
framing of this video is so weird i'm so
low it's because i have this big pile of
trash next to me right here that i'm
trying to frame out it's because it's
stuff for this like sketch video that i
don't know if i can throw out yet so i
have to kind of leave it there and it's
really difficult to pack back up so
it is what it is you can kind of see it
if you have any questions for next
month's video leave them in the comments
of this video you can always come back
and leave them if you want uh to get a
question in for my next q a i see people
do that all the time just leave a
question in the comments of the previous
q a and i will answer them in the next q
a like i said i do now also have q and
a's up on a different channel where i
talk about tv movies personal whatever
stuff that isn't video games uh that is
alana irl youtube.com social wanna irl
that is it for me today everyone a huge
thank you to best buy for sponsoring
this video check the link in the
description for more about that
beautiful laptop and i will see you guys
next time